[موسيقى]
يشتهر اليرسانيون بما يسمى مجالس الجم وهي
مجالس دينيه بدات في القرن الحادي عشر
وكان مؤسسها الشيخ خشيم حيث تمت تسميته
هذه المجالس سابقا باسم سنجاري وظهرت في
هذه الحلقات التي تكون على شكل اغان
وابتهالات جميع قواعد ومعتقدات الطائفه
اليارسانيه والتي تستعمل اله التنور لانهم
حسب معتقداتهم من اقدم واقدس الالات التي
يعود تاريخها الى اكثر من 5,000 عام قبل
الميلاد
ويتجلى اعتقادهم ان الموسيقى تعيد للروح
موضعها
[موسيقى]
عرسان
بشكل عام بشكل الموسيقى عندهم اهميه كبيره
وهي مقدسه لديهم لانهم يعتقدون انها صوت
الحقيقه وهي صوت الرب لان الموسيقى
بالاساس جاءت من الطبيعه
القديمه ومعتقدتهم ان اول صوت وجد في
الكون هو صوت الطنبور وان روح الانسان قد
استانست وسعدت صوت هذه الاله
ذكر في الاسلام يسمونها حلقه ذكر ونحن
نسميها وقت تمديد الله وهذا ما تشاهدونه
في بعض افلام الفيديو حيث تجلس النساء مع
الرجال بصوره مشتركه ويعزفون على اله
التنوره بعد الاناشيد الدينيه وهذه
الحلقات عاده ما تكون في المناسبات وخاصه
الاعياد
[موسيقى]
ثاني عيني شاكي برمانه المساواه بين
الرجال والنساء في الدين الكتاكيت واضحه
في تقوسهم وممارستهم كما ترون في الفيديو
بشكل واضح تجلس النساء مع الرجال ويعزفون
على الطنبور معانا وتظهر ايضا الاشياء
المقدسه في ديانتنا والشيء الاول المقدس
هو اله الطنبور التي تعزف بها الاناشيد
الدينيه وقبل البدء بالعزف يجب على العزف
او العازفه تقبيل اله الطنبور
[موسيقى]
عندما يتوجه مجموعه من الاشخاص الى مكان
معين ويكون معهم شخص يحمل اله الطنبور فلن
يدخل هؤلاء الاشخاص الى ذلك المكان حتى
يتقدمهم من يحمل اله التنبور وهذا الفعل
هو احتراما لاله الطنبور لان صوته هو صوت
الحقيقه وصوت الكوني في الاساس وقد وجد
الباحثون في الاثار في عده اماكن ومزارات
رسوما او منحوتات على شكل انسان يعزف على
اله التنبور وتلك الاثار يعود تاريخها الى
خمسه او سته الاف عام مضت لذلك سميت هذه
الاله الام او الاصل لكل الالات الموسيقيه
الشرقيه فالاله وبالذات الشرقيه منها تم
استنباطها من اله التامور